♪ ♪
>> Tammy: THE GREAT STATE OF
TEXAS AND ARIZONA HAVE BEEN
BUSTING MIGRANTS FROM THE BORDER
TO LIBERAL SANCTUARY CITIES FOR
MONTHS BUT RECENTLY TEXAS ADDED
A NEW DESTINATION FOR MIGRANTS:
CHICAGO.
THE FIRST BUS ARRIVED EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND THE CITY'S MAYOR
WAS NOT TOO HAPPY ABOUT IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THESE CONTINUED POLITICAL
STUNTS, GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS
CONFIRMED UNFORTUNATE WHAT MANY
OF US HAD ALREADY KNOWN.
BUT HE'S A MAN WITHOUT ANY
MORALS.
>> Tammy: IN A STATEMENT TO
FOX NEWS, SPOKESPERSON FOR
ABBOTT ASKED WHERE THE OUTRAGE
WAS WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN FLEW
MIGRANTS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY IN
THE MIDDLE THE NIGHT.
MEANWHILE IN THE STATE OF NEVADA
WERE OPEN BORDERS ARE ALSO A BIG
ISSUE, NEW POLL SHOWS CLOSE
RACES FOR GOVERNOR AND SENATOR
IN THE STATE THANKS IN PART TO A
COLLAPSE OF SUPPORT FOR
DEMOCRATS AMONG HISPANICS.
IN FACT, REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
AND FORMER STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ADAM LAXALT FINDS
HIMSELF IN A VIRTUAL TIE WITH
THE INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT
SENATOR CATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO
IN A HEAD-TO-HEAD RACE AND
JOINING US IS IN FACT THAT MAN,
ADAM LAXALT.
ADAM, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
AS AN AMERICAN, IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHICH STATE WE LIVE IN.
WE CARE ABOUT ALL THAT WAS
HAPPENING.
CRIME MATTERS TO ALL OF US.
SCHOOLING MATTERS TO ALL OF US
AND YET WE DO SEE, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SEE THE HYPOCRISY
HERE.
THE REMARKABLE REACTION OF
LORI LIGHTFOOT TO SIMPLY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ASKED TO GO TO CHICAGO
BEING IN A BUS AND SHE SMEARS
GOVERNOR ABBOTT WINS SINCE SHE
HAS BEEN ELECTED IN 2019 TO
2022, MURDERS HAVE INCREASED
34%.
SHE SAYS GREG ABBOTT IS THE MAN
WITH NO SHAME AND WHO IS
IMMORAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
WITH LORI LIGHTFOOT AT THIS
POINT?
WHAT'S YOUR PROBLEM?
>> LOOK, HOW ABOUT YOU CALL OUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND WHILE YOU'RE
AT IT, HOW ABOUT
SENATOR MANSEAU, PRESIDENT BIDEN
FOR THIS OPEN BORDER.
THIS IS CAUSING MASSIVE MISERY
IN THIS COUNTRY, RECORD SPIKES
AND FENTANYL.
I'M IN THE RURAL TOWN IN NEVADA.
THEY ARE BEING OVERRUN WITH
FENTANYL OVERDOSES.
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN.
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HERE THEY CAN'T HANDLE THE STUFF
WITHOUT SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
FOR THESE MAYORS TO COMPLAIN
THAT IT'S FINALLY HITTING THEIR
CITY, WHEN STATES LIKE MINE AND
COMMUNITIES LIKE ELKO NEVADA
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH IT FOR
MANY YEARS, IT'S PREPOSTEROUS
AND OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tammy: IT ALMOST SEEMS LIKE
DEFLECTION BUT THIS IS WHAT IS
SO GHOULISH ABOUT IT.
SHE KNOWS SHE IS SETTING UP HER
CITY AS A SANCTUARY CITY
SANCTUARY CITY.
THAT'S IMPORTANT WORD.
THEY HAVE INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE
TO COME.
TAXES ARE HIGH.
SHE WON BY OVER 75% WHEN SHE WAS
ELECTED SO THE PEOPLE OF CHICAGO
EMBRACE THESE POLICIES BUT THE
MOMENT IT'S ACTED ON, SHE GETS
ANGRY.
IT'S AS THOUGH SHE'S EITHER
TRYING TO HIDE OR SHE NEVER
MEANT IT AND THAT THIS WAS ALL
FAKE.
>> THIS IS THE WORLD WE LIVE IN
EVERY DAY.
LOOK AT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S SPEECH
LAST NIGHT.
HE DIDN'T MENTION FENTANYL
OVERDOSES, THE OPEN BORDER, THE
CRASHING ECONOMY, RECORD HIGHS
AND INFLATION.
WEDNESDAY DO?
HE CREATED A WHOLE NEW NARRATIVE
AND SMEARED HALF OF AMERICANS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
THEY DENIGRATE PEOPLE.
THEY ATTACK PEOPLE.
THEY TRY TO DEFLECT FROM THEIR
TERRIBLE POLICIES THAT ARE
WRECKING MY GREAT STATE AND
WRECKING CITIES ALL ACROSS
AMERICA.
>> Tammy: EXCELLENT POINT.
HE SAID NOTHING ABOUT THE CRISIS
HITTING EVERY AMERICAN TO MATTER
WHAT PAR